Es sind alle ein bisschen zu konstruktiv unterwegs, ja.
Ja, wir müssen mehr disruptiv...
Da jagen die Fabriker die Polizisten so. .
Hall. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen neuen Ausgabe von DPU, das Podcast Ufe, für dich und mich und uns und uns, das bin ich und Stefan Tietze. Wir sind das Podcast Ufe und wir machen das für euch da draußen. Ja, nur für euch. Uns gibt das gar nichts. Wir haben davon nichts, wir hassen das, seit Jahren quälen wir uns zu jeder Aufgabe. Wir kommen hier rein, sind voller Freude, danach sind wir richtig deprimiert, runtergezogen. Ich mag Florentin nicht, Florentin hasst mich und ja, wir machen uns so wenig da draußen, nur dass du Bescheid wirst. Ja, es ist immer eine richtig unangenehme Stimmung, kurz bevor es losgeht, wir müssen zusammen durch die teilweise sehr, sehr langen Intros sitzen. Wir schweigen uns an, wir schweigen uns nicht in die Augen. Kein Muskel des Körpers bewegt sich, auch wenn sie danceable sind. Manchmal zucke ich ein bisschen, aber nein. Vielen Dank für dieses fantastische Intro von Jan, der uns in eine illustre Parallelwelt führt, in der Verbrecher die Polizei jagen. Ganz interessant, ein kleiner Ausblick in das Universum, das Oeuvre, das Jan dort geschaffen hat. Das Oeuvre, und das kann man auch sagen, ist das Stilmittel, das komödiantische Stilmittel der Inversion. Sehr gut. Wir invertieren die Welt. Ich habe mich schon gefragt, Stefan Thielze zwei Wochen in der Hansestadt Hamburg unterwegs unter hohen Leuten trägt ein Jackett, trägt eine Weste, trägt ein Three-Piece-Suit. Ich dachte mir, jetzt kommt euch wieder an, der Kölle Jung, wie hat er sich verändert und er ist nicht mehr wiederzuerkennen. Nein, nein, nein, ich war an der Hanse. Ich war, ich weiß nicht genau, was die Hanse ist. Ich habe gerade grob was mit Handeln zu tun, glaube ich. Das ist alles, was ich darüber weiß. Hanseln. Ich glaube, wenn du Hanseln willst, gehst du zu Hanse. Oder zu Gretel. Ich war jedenfalls in der Hansestadt Hamburg, in der Hänselstadt Hamburg und habe da ein bisschen Schach kommentiert. Oh, schön. Ich habe etwas von meiner Bucketlist gestrichen, von dem ich nicht mehr wusste, dass es auf meiner Bucketlist ist. Ich habe zwei Wochen Schach kommentiert mit dem großartigen Gustavsson, das war sehr lustig. Ich bin sehr müde und ich bin heute gerade eben erst vor dieser Aufnahme just zurückgekommen aus Hamburg im ICE. Zuganekdote? Pass auch. Stefan! Erstmal! Leute, freut euch auf eine tolle Zuganekdote. Immer passiert irgendwas Verrücktes. Nein, Flotin, ganz was. Irgendein Typ fällt um und dann musste Stefan den Notarzt rufen. Flotin,zt rufen oder irgendein Kind hangelt sich über die Gepäckleiste, ich bin so gespannt. Hör mir zu, hör mir zu, okay? Es ist nichts passiert. Wie ist es nichts passiert? Nee, es tut mir leid, ich bin im Zug gefahren, natürlich, und ich wusste, dass danach die Podcastaufnahme ist. Moment, du bist mit dem ICE gefahren und da war nicht irgendjemand laut oder hat jemand mit seiner Freundin am Handy Schluss gemacht und du hast es überhört und hast ihm einen Tipps gegeben, wie man Schluss macht? Nein, es war auch nicht das Bordbistro zu und es ging nicht und dann, oh, wir haben nur noch dieses alte Sandwich, nein, es war nichts passiert. Es ist nicht, irgendwie hat man seine Thermoskanne Kaffee ausgelaufen und das ist dann hin und her geschwappt, immer wenn der Zug Gas gegeben und gebremst hat? Nein, neben mir war auch kein Rennepaar, was rohe Eier gegessen hat, was rohe Eier sich gegenseitig in die Münder gegossen hat. Und es war nicht so voll, dass die Leute aufeinander sich stapeln mussten? Nein, es war super leer. Es ist nichts passiert. Das kann nicht sein. Denk nochmal nach, da muss irgendwas passiert sein. Beim Einsteigen ist dir dein Handy aus der Tasche gefallen, ist in die Gleisbett gefallen. Nee, hier ist es noch. Auch meine Airpods waren fast leer, aber dann hat es doch noch gereicht. Beim Aussteigen bist du mit deinem T-Shirt hängen geblieben und du hattest kurz Angst, dass die Tür zugeht, du hängen bleibst und mit nach Hannover geschliffen wirst. Nein, aber hey, hey, mir ist was eingefallen, mir ist was eingefallen. Yes! Hier kommt die Podcast-Uvo, die ICE-Anekdote, Ote, Ote. Naja, es war nicht so besonders, aber die Steckdosen haben nicht funktioniert. Aber dann hat es doch noch gereicht. Und dann habe ich mein Laptop, dann wurde immer leerer, immer leerer, aber am Ende hat es noch genau gepasst. Ich meine, die haben riesige Stromabnehmer über dem gesamten Gleis und da kann Stefan T. nicht ein bisschen was abkommen. Nee, weil ich meine, weil der Zug fährt ja mit Strom, warum hat der keinen Strom? Ja, ja, aber das ist nicht so lustig. Also das musst du dich damit abfinden. Aber ich meine ja, weil es ist ja nicht so, dass der Du musst dir damit abfinden, dass es keine lustige ICE-Fahrt war. Das war die Podcast-Ufung-Zug-Anechtote.
Ja toll, ich habe ja ganz leidenschaftlich mitverfolgt, was ihr da getrieben habt bei euch in der Schachkommentarkabine. Krieg ich jetzt eigentlich Geld zurück? Krieg ich als Podcast jetzt das Geld zurück, ist meine Frage.
Also jeder Zuhörer kriegt jetzt so ein Fahrgastformular von der Bahn.
Ja, weil die haben ja ein Leben am Ende und haben gesagt, es tut uns sehr leid, es ist nichts passiert und sie können diese ganze Zugfahrt nicht für den Podcast verwerten und dann haben sie mir diesen Zettel gegeben. Aber ich habe mich geärgert, weil ich kann das nicht direkt von Ihnen jetzt Geld bekommen. Du kannst beim Kundenservice den Zettel abgeben und dann kriegst du innerhalb von 90 Tagen eine Anekdote nachgereicht. Ich muss jetzt eine Anekdote nachgereicht? Du kriegst eine Anekdote nachgereicht? Du kriegst eine Anekdote nachgereicht. Du kriegst den Zugpreis zurück.
Du musst das Fahrgastformular einreichen, dann kriegst du die Anekdote zurück.
Und alle Hörer dürfen jetzt auch bei der Bahn beim Kundenservice ein Fahrgastformular einreichen und kriegen da auch nochmal eine Ex-Anekdote.
Eine Gratis-Anekdote.
Und fünf Euro Bordbistro-Gutsche.
Aber Zugbindung, achtet auf die Zugbindung.
Die Anekdotenbindung, sie müssen dann aber auch wirklich genau die erzählen und keine andere.
Es gibt Anekdotenbildung, manchmal gibt es so Wechsel, aber da müsst ihr ganz spontan, müsst ihr gucken, da müsst ihr auf den Anekdotenwechsel in veränderter Reihenfolge, dass manchmal sind die dann... Kommt erst die Pointe und dann die Geschichte. Typisch Bahn! Ja, da müsst ihr mal gucken und manchmal kommt es ein bisschen zu spät, aber dann wird es schon raus. Okay, ihr kriegt das schon hin, es ist super einfach. Ihr kriegt das schon hin. Es ist nicht absichtlich kompliziert gemacht, damit es möglichst wenig Leute machen.
Nee, aber hat mir total gut gefallen, was ihr da gesagt habt über Schach erzählt. Da habt ihr was erzählt von den schwarzen Feldern, den weissen Feldern und dann rutschen die Figuren da hin und her und also das war eine helle Freude und viel habe ich nicht verstanden, gebe ich ganz ehrlich zu. Ich auch nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Ich gebe es offen und echt zu.
Es war toll, viele Wortwitze bieten sich ja an. Ich dachte mir nur, ich habe mir Sorgen gemacht, wohin geht deine Karriere jetzt, weil du bist an einem Höhepunkt, besser geht's nicht, Top-Kommentator, besser deutsche Top-Kommentator, du bist die Schachlegende, wohin geht's jetzt? Du meintest, das Schachmagazin wurde dir verwehrt, wohin geht's jetzt? Und dann ist mir eingefallen, jeder Mensch, der in der Öffentlichkeit steht und am Höhepunkt seiner Karriere ist, hat zwei Möglichkeiten. Drogen? Entweder Buch oder ein Album. Okay, oder ein Hörbuchalbum. Oder ein eingesprochenes oder ein gesungenes Buch. Ja. Ich glaube, bei dir könnte es das Album werden, und zwar dachte ich bei dir an so einen ganz schmierigen Schlager-Einschlag zum Thema Schach. Also so Klassiker wie Mein Herz steht Schachmatt. Ja, ja, lustigerweise haben wir das auch für Jan Gustav von überlegt. Ich finde das super. Ich finde Schach und Schlager ist wirklich eine Welt, die gehört zusammen. Rösselsprung? Ja, die Läufer erst, die Springer dann, so fängt man die Entwicklung an. Mein Herz springt im Rösselsprung, wir machen die grosse Rochade zusammen. Ich roch hier direkt in dein Herz. Ah, herrlich! Genau so muss es sein. Genauso muss es sein. Ich finde es gut, also Schach bietet sich an. Total, weil es kennt jeder, jeder weiss grob, was die Figuren machen, aber nicht genau. Und es ist ja ein sehr leidenschaftlicher Sport, glaube ich, kann man sagen. Ja genau, auch so irgendwie, keine Ahnung, also so, Jan hat irgendwann mal gesagt, ein Springer braucht Halt. Weil es muss immer ein Bauer hinter dem Springer stehen, damit der Springer gesichert wird. Das ist ja wunderschön, das ist poesig. Ein Springer braucht Halt? Ja, auch ich brauche Halt. Ich möchte dir diesen Song singen. Ein Springer braucht Halt. Anders als im echten Leben, da geben Pferde Halt. Pferde geben Halt. Pferde sind erstmal selber relativ, ich meine, ein Pferd sei ein Pferd, kann man auch sagen, weil ein Pferd, die meisten Tiere kriegen es gerade so hin zu stehen, also ihr eigenes Körpergewicht zu tragen. Das Pferd sagt, wir haben noch ein paar Kilo.
Da kann sich gern noch jemand draufsetzen.
Ich kann unendlich weit laufen, und mein Mega-Feature ist,
ich kann auch mit dir auf meinem Rücken unendlich weit laufen.
Unmerklich wenig weniger.
Ich mein, so ein Reh, da kannst du nicht mal ein Kleinkind draufsetzen,
es bricht zusammen, wohingegen ein Pferd, nö, merke ich kaum.
Ich hab mal das Cowboy-Spiel Red Dead Redemption gespieltpielt und da steht irgendwann unten, ihr Pferd wird müde. Und ich dachte, nein, nein, und schön weiter, schön weiter peitschen, schön weiter gepeitscht, slash R2 gedrückt. Also ich bin weiter feucht vor die Prärie geritten, wurde dann tatsächlich müde, aber ich habe es für Quatsch gehalten, ich dachte, das ist nicht aus dem Leben gegriffen. Pferde werden nicht müde. Nein, Pferde werden nicht müde. Pferde gehen nicht ins Bett, Pferde machen die Nacht durch. Dann habe ich neulich so einen langweiligen Film geschaut, ich weiß nicht, wie der heißt, aber da ist ein Pferd gestorben. Exodus heißt Easter Film. Wow. Nicht Ecos? Mit Daniel Radcliffe? Ist es ein Film? Ist es ein Theaterstück? Nee, daran hätte ich mich erinnert, wenn ich in London ein Theaterstück gesehen hätte. Wo, ich meine, alle nackt sind auch. Genau, das war der grosse Aufmerker damals. Daran hätte ich mich erinnert. Harry Potter, der grosse Jugend hält, straight into nackt am Theater. Guter Move, guter Move. Man muss sich emanzipieren von seiner Kinderstarrolle.
Wie auch geschehen Robert Pattinson sieht man jetzt total gerne in The Life of the Devil all the time.
Tolle Filme. Alle machen jetzt so Arthausland-Kram, weil die wollen sich natürlich absondern.
Wir können auch anders.
Ja, genau.
Aber es ist so ein bisschen immer, also die finden oft nicht die Mitte.
Nee, nee, du musst dann ja überkompensieren.
Natalie Portman findet die Mitte, finde ich.
Laura Dern findet die Mitte. Also das ist die Jurassic Park, ist eine gute Mitte. Ja, aber da war sie ja kein Kind. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, neinbuster. Dabei kann sie mehr, ja, sie kann viel mehr. Sie kann auch für David Lynch vor die Kamera, vor die Kamera. Aber Star Wars 8, was hat sie da gemacht? War das denn rückenblickend eine gute Idee? Ich bin offensichtlich der weniger begabte Teil dieses Gesangsduos. Ja. Sie sollten sich von dem Partner trennen, Stefan.
Nein, also, Laura hat's geschafft.
Die spielt in den Blockbuster, die spielt in den grossen Lynch,
für mich, und hat's geschafft. Ja, absolut. Ich spiele den Blockbuster. Die spielt den großen Lynch-Film. Die macht alles. Und das ist toll. Die schafft auch die Mitte. Und ich finde, Robert Pattinson und Harry Potter haben es nicht geschafft, die Mitte zu finden. Gut, doch, Tenet. Robert Pattinson hat es geschafft, die Mitte zu finden. Ja, absolut der Mainstream, aber auch The Lighthouse. Und finde ich eine gute Idee. Derjenige war so super Art-Housey. Und derjenigeiffe auch mit Swiss Army Man, also das ist Gegenteil von Harry Potter. Aber auch cool, war auch lustig. Du musst überkompensieren. Deswegen rate ich auch dir, du bist jetzt natürlich in der intellektuellen Szene angekommen. Du hast jetzt das Jackett an, du hast den Hut auf, du hast die Krawatte an. Ich wollte mal den Chess24-Chat, ob ich in der intellektuellen Erwachsenenwelt angekommen bin. Ich glaube, du musst jetzt wieder gegenkompensieren. Du musst jetzt richtig auf die Strasse. Ich will von dir Breakdance sehen, Graffiti, Hip-Hop, Sprechgesang, ich will von dir richtig harte, grobe, verbale Ausschreitungen.
Ja, ich habe auch schon überlegt, hier auf dem Weg hierher, ich muss eigentlich so eine Häuserwand anpinkeln oder so was. Irgendwie mal was Krasses. Das ist was Krasses, was mir eingefallen.
Einfach mal so eine Nacht, wenn man so durch die Strasse, weil wir jetzt auch alles gerade Corona-bedingt leer, einfach mal so ein Schaufenster eintreten. Ja.
Von so einem Donutladen.
Und dann so Donut selber machen.
Und der Donutbesitzer am nächsten Tag völlig entrüstet, wer mag denn keine Donuts?
Ich hasse Donuts.
Ich dachte, alle Menschen lieben Donuts, deswegen habe ich diesen DonutladLaden aufgemacht und jetzt macht jemand meinen Schaufenster. Wer sind Sie? Ich habe den Tatort nicht verlassen. Anscheinend nicht. Haben Sie mein Schaufenster zerstört? Nee, nachts hatte ich Hunger, wollte ein Donut mir selber machen. Ach so, ja dann kein Problem. Hier ist meine Nummer, rufen Sie mich gerne jederzeit an, falls Sie einen Donut brauchen. What a nice guy. Ich dachte, jemand mag keine Donuts. Das hätte mein Weltbild zerstört. Wirklich. Mr. Donut, vielen Dank. Gerne, natürlich. Sie sind der netteste Mensch der Welt. Rufen Sie mich gerne an, na klar. Es tut mir so leid, dass ich Ihre Schaufenster-Scheibe kaputt gemacht habe. Aber ich meine, wenn dir wirklich so eine Filiale gehört. Ich meine, wir alle kennen das, wenn wir in der Nähe, also zum Beispiel ich bin in Bayern aufgewachsen, in München, da machen Geschäfte um 22 Uhr zu. Schluss, 20 Uhr, Schluss, da ist aus. Das heißt, selbst wenn du um 23 Uhr nochmal dir denkst, oh, so eine kleine Packung Erdnuss M&Ms, gibt's, geht nicht. Wohingegen, wenn du neben einem Bahnhof wohnst, der einfach 24-7 offen hat, vielleicht sogar ein Automat, kannst du da selbst um ein Uhr nachts nochmal mit deinen Pantoffeln und deiner Schlafmütze dir irgendwie so Malteser holen. Was ist, wenn du der Besitzer von einem Donutladen bist und dir um zwei Uhr nachts denkst, ich kann nicht schlafen, ich habe jetzt Bock auf ein Creme gefüllt, machst du dann nochmal selber die Fritteuse an, wenn du es kannst, jederzeit! Du hast einen Waffelladen. Ich finde es super. Ist die Frage, ob man nicht des eigenen Materials überdrüssig wird. Ja, kann sein. Ich bin nicht froh. Genitiv ist ein Commitment. Und als ich da rausgekommen bin, Props, weil Genitiv musst du am Anfang, in der deutschen Sprache musst du am Anfang, dich komm mitten auf dem Genitiv und dann viel Spaß on the road.
Gegen Ende, ja. Du hast einen Riesenanlauf genommen, bist auf die Ölspunk gekommen, Öl auf Eis, du bist in Schleuder gekommen, ins Rutschen gekommen, aber hast die Lammung perfekt genannt.
Aber man muss es dann landen, du musst, im Genitiv musst du stehen.
Ja, im Genitiv musst du wirklich stehen, da darfst du nicht einen Zentimeter wackeln.
Aber ganz im Ernst, ich bin ein bisschen stolz auf mich gerade, weil ich habe, oder auch ein bisschen enttäuscht, ich weiß es noch nicht, entscheide selbst.
Denn ich habe gegen meine eigene riesengroße Regel, das war eine meiner Topregeln, habe ich gerade verstoßen mit dieser Aufnahme hier, denn heute ist Reisetag, heute ist mein Reisetag. Und meine Regel ist, an Reisetagen muss ich gar nichts mehr machen. Ohne Scheiß, das ist eine gute Regel, liebe Leute. Das ist eine Superregel. Aber man darf sich nicht nur auf sich anwenden, dann ist man ein egoistisches Arschloch, was oft nichts mehr macht, sondern man muss auch anderen diese Freiheit geben. Wenn andere einen Reitetag haben, ruft die nicht mehr an. Die haben eine Reise hinter sich. Die müssen es niemandem beweisen. Die haben vielleicht was im IC erlebt. Die haben was erlebt vielleicht, wäre auch nicht, ist egal. Die haben einen anstrengenden Reitetag hinter sich. Weil ich habe irgendwie irgendwann mal gemerkt, dass ich psychologisch nicht in der Lage bin, wenn ich, und wenn es nur so eine kurze Autofahrt ist, sagen wir mal, es muss immer so über anderthalb Stunden gehen, das ist schon so die Regel für einen Reisetag. Aber länger als anderthalb Stunden ist es sofort ein Reisetag und da habe ich dann auch oft nicht mehr den Kopf für was anderes. Wenn diese Autofahrt ansteht, irgendwie um 14 Uhr, bin ich bis 14 Uhr nicht zu gebrauchen. Überhaupt nicht. Und dann bin ich angekommen und dann will ich erst mal auch ankommen.
So, dann brauche ich, dann brauche ich erst mal,
muss ich mich akklimatisieren, dann sieht man sich erst mal um,
dann ist man da, so.
Was habe ich verpasst während der Fahrt, was ist
passiert im Internet? Genau. Alles noch mal
nachholen, nachchecken. Richtig.
Ich meine, es ist ja, wenn man sich mal den Menschen
Evolutionär anschaut, der kann ja nicht dafür gemacht
sein, schlagartig, hunderte Kilometer weit weg aufzutauchen. Ich denke mir das immer, wenn du eine Wespe im Auto hast und dann machst du das Fels auf und die Wespen viel brauchen. Ich denke mir, forget it, die Wespe ist erledigt. Bist du erledigt? Ist sie erledigt? Ich weiß nicht, ob sie erledigt ist. Du kannst doch nicht als Fremdwespe einfach zu einem neuen Wespenstock geben und sagen, salut, je m'appelle. Ich habe mich gerade gedacht, ich habe mich gerade gedacht, du fliegst über die französische Grenze, lässt die Wespe da raus. Ich würde auch unscheiz auf der Autobahn, Wespe im Auto, ich dreh um, fahr nach Frankreich. Ja, nochmal zurück. Nein, Frankreich. Ja, okay, man sollte zurück Nein, ich dachte gerade an was anderes, straight Frankreich. Rein.
Stimmt, bringen die Bieste alle nach Frankreich.
Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Ja.
Und dann soll die mal da klarkommen, im anderen Land.
Ich weiß gar nicht, also gerne, falls Insektenforscher und Forscherinnen zuhören, schreibt uns gerne, ob die wirklich Anschluss finden, ob es da so eine Art Aufnahmegruppe, so eine Tourist Information Bureau gibt, wo man sich meldet und sagt, Entschuldigen Sie, ich habe nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung, wo ich bin.
Können Sie mir weiterhelfen? Ich bin Wespe, ich habe gearbeitet, ich habe da die Außenwände gemacht bei dem Wespen-Nest, den Stock, die äusserste Hülle, die habe ich gemacht von außen. Ein Moment. Genau. Und ansonsten. Natürlich ist eine Spinne, natürlich ist eine Spinne am Empfang, die mit ihren acht lächerlichen Ärmchen. Büro. Und ansonsten … Natürlich ist eine Spinne, natürlich ist eine Spinne am Empfang, die mit ihren acht lächerlichen Ärmchen … Ja, ja. Und ansonsten, ich war Lang- und Tischtennisverein, ich koche ganz gerne und was ich auch ganz gerne mache, ist so Dia-Abende, über Reisen und so, wenn man sich mit Freunden trifft. Also da fände ich es auch gut, wenn ich irgendwo da Anschluss finde. Okay, dann einen Moment. Und so, wenn Sie dort mal hinten in dieses Büro, Büro 18, da sehen Sie Gary, den Gottesanbeter. Zudem gehen Sie einfach hin und der wird Sie alsbald an Ihren neuen Stamm vermitteln. Viel Spaß, danke schön. Hier ist Ihre Nummer. Ja, vielen Dank, danke schön. Und dann sitzt man 18 Stunden da und lebt nicht mehr. Und der Gottesan mir der Frist ein und sagt, ich konnte mich nicht zurückhalten.
Es tut mir,
Gary, warum haben Sie diesen Job?
Sie haben ja den Kunden gefressen. Es tut mir leid,
habe ich gesagt und weg raus.
Insekt im Sitcom.
Aber das stimmt
und ich habe auch die, ich habe
ein super Beispiel, was du sagst mit der Wespe.
Man ist plötzlich woanders, der Mensch oder auch andere Lebewesen sind nicht dafür gemacht. Anderes Beispiel Fische. Wenn du Fische neu kaufst, in einem Gartencenter oder in einem Zoo-Ding, und dann soll man sie nämlich nicht sofort in das eigene Aquarium werfen, sondern man soll erst mal diesen Beutel oben reinhängen, damit so Wäscheklammern befestigen und dann so alle zehn Minuten nimmt man so eine ordentliche Tasse Aquariumwasser und macht's rein, damit man die langsam an die Wasserqualität, an die offensichtlich schlechtere Wasserqualität bei einem selbst gewöhnt. Und das ist so ein bisschen was, was ich denke, ja, Menschen haben das nicht, auf Menschen nimmt man nicht so Rücksicht. Wir Menschen kommen an irgendwo in Hamburg, nach nur vier Stunden. Plötzlich schlagartig, Krobak, neue Stadt. Krobak, Ditsch, alles ist anders, McDonalds, was soll das sein? Man kommt nicht klar. Alles ist anders, alle sprechen leicht anders, so damit kommt man nicht sofort klar. Das ist ein so krasser Tapetenwechsel und deswegen bin ich dafür, dass wir den Reisetag einführen. Ihr müsst nie jemandem immer was beweisen, ihr müsst nichts mehr machen, ihr müsst nicht mehr ins Telefon gehen, schreibt noch euren Liebsten, dass ihr angekommen seid. Okay, aber nichts machen mehr. Ich finde auch deinen Hinweis sehr gut darauf, dass es auch von der anderen Seite gelten sollte. Wenn ihr wisst, die Person reist am Tag, nicht anschreiben, nicht ein Smiley, nicht ein oh, guck mal, lustiges Gif. Ich habe keine Zeit für Unterhaltung. Ist das ein lustiges Gif, da fällt ein Bär vom Baum, das ist ein Renner. Aber morgen, gerne morgen, nicht heute.
Gerne morgen. Ich bin nicht dafür, ich habe auch einen Kumpel, der wohnt in einem anderen Land, wenn er am Anfang zukommt und so an dem Reisetag nicht behelligen. Du hast Reisetag, entspann dich, ich besorge dir was zu trinken. Ist natürlich schwierig, wenn du sagen wir mal einen Freund vom Bahnhof abholst, der kommt irgendwie aus Luxemburg, besucht dich, kommt an, ist erstmal völlig desorientiert, oben, unten, links, rechts, die Katzen jagen Hunde, was ist hier los? Und dann fährst du den aber zu dir nach Hause, auch hier kein Gesprächsthema, Stille, leichtes Radio, ganz zart. Zartes Radio, ganz zart. Zartes Klassikradio, hauchzart. Nicht so ein Gespräch, balla balla balla Deutschlandfunk, nein. Ja, nein, nein, nein, nicht, wo geht's hin mit der Politik, sondern Deutschlandfunk, Kultur. Nova. Klassik, ich finde das immer eine Beleidigung, wenn die sagen beim Klassikradio, Klassik zum Entspannen. Also ich finde das immer so, was soll das denn heißen, als ob ein gesamtes Genremusik, Jahrhunderte, tausende Genies die Musik geschrieben habt und ihr, ja zum Entspannen, äh sorry, als ob Wagner seine fucking Oper geschrieben hat mit einem 300 Mann Chor und sagt, ja die Leute sollen sich mal sechs Stunden lang entspannen können. Damit ihr mal an nichts denken müsst, damit ihr euren Urlaub fürs Hirn einfach mal kurz schön abschalten und brücken an und Bruckner an. Das ist, wenn du denkst, es ist selbst als Klassikradio, wie kann man denn so wenig Respekt vor dem Genre haben? Wobei Bruckner ein gutes Beispiel ist für jemanden, dem das negativ aufgestoßen ist, weil er oft nach so langsamen Geigenparts und oft einfach Ramm, Ramm, Ramm, Ramm, Klatsch, Hallo! Ja, kurz so ein, hey, das ist nichts zum Entspannen, ich bin das Gegenteil, hallo! Nee, also ich finde das immer dreist, ich bin da immer kurz davor anzurufen und zu sagen, sag mal was fällt Ihnen denn ein? Sie müssen heute an nichts mehr denken, Sie lehnen sich einfach zurück, Sie müssen, Sie haben keine Sorgen mehr, hier kommt irgendein Klassik-Kram. Genau, irgendein Gedüdel mit einer Fidel, los geht's. Wir haben so ein Rumgedudel. Wie, das haben wir den ganzen Tag schon gespielt? Egal, wir spielen es nochmal. Wir spielen es nochmal. Klingt eh alles gleich. Es klingt alles gleich. Ist doch eh egal. Ja, Moderatoren beim Klassikreide, die Klassikreide nicht zu schätzen wissen. Die klassische Musik hassen einfach. Auch wenn sie sich hassen, despektierlich behandeln. Naja. Nee, aber ich finde es okay. Ich habe Reisetag gehabt, trotzdem bin ich heute hier und ich bin bereit.
Finde ich toll.
Man muss auch Ausnahmen machen können.
Ja.
Wenn man die Regeln beherrscht, dann kann man sich auch brechen.
Genau.
Man muss die Regeln nur beherrschen.
Ja, und es muss von dir ausgehen.
Ich kann nicht am Reisetag sagen und sagen, ja, Stefan, nein, nein, nein, nein, sondern du musst sagen, ich bin heute trotzdem bereit und dann freue ich mich auch und dann weiss ich, dass es dir wert ist. Aber dann ist es auch ein Bonus, dann kann man aber auch am nächsten Tag vielleicht, aber ich finde es gut, ab und zu sich so Grenzen zu stecken und zu sagen, weil das kam auch daher, ich dachte nämlich, ah, ich habe ein komisches Gefühl, ich bin jetzt gereist den Tag, heute Abend habe ich noch einen Termin, gefällt mir nicht, gefällt mir nicht, gefällt mir nicht, um dem ich jetzt trotzdem war, und da habe ich mir so gedacht, es ist voll okay, dass ich dieses Gefühl habe, manchmal ist es voll okay, Faulheit zu verspüren und da da muss man auch mal sich solche Grenzen stecken. Die Regel kam ja bei mir daher, dass ich dachte, ich muss hier niemandem mehr gerecht werden. Ich muss auf mein Gefühl hören. Und mein Gefühl sagt, du machst heute gar nichts mehr. Das ist alles im ICE passiert? Das ist im ICE passiert oder am Bahnhof? Nee, das ist schon vor Jahren irgendwann mal im ICE passiert. Okay, na gut. Hast du solche Regeln? Ich hab's manchmal auch Sonntag. Heute ist Sonntag, heute muss ich nichts mehr machen. Heute muss sich niemandem mehr was beweisen. Heute ist der heilige Sonntag. Kein bisschen gläubig, aber heute ist der heilige Sonntag. Ich meine, wenn Gott am Sonntag mal kurz gesagt hat, jetzt mal die Beine hoch und Klassikradio an, dann kann ich das doch auch. Wenn er gesagt hat, ach nee, wie die Krähen, die können gar nicht fliegen, ist mir egal. Was, Frösche und Kröten sind fast dasselbe, sagt ihr, lass uns da morgen drüber reden, ist mir egal. Streusse können nicht fliegen, die laufen nur schnell und stecken ihren Back, weil die den Kopf in den Sand stecken. Ja, das machen wir morgen, das ist egal. Weißt du was, das machen wir am Montag, das machen wir nächste Woche in Ruhe. Man muss auch sagen, Gott, die erste Woche extrem produktiv, danach ein bisschen abgefallen. Nicht mehr zurückkommen, nicht mehr ins Büro gekommen. Nach seinem ersten Album nicht mehr zurückgekommen. Ich mache Homeoffice, hat er gesagt. Ciao, ich mache Homeoffice. Ich mache Homeoffice und so 500 Jahre später, Ähm ... Entschuldigung, Herr Gott, wir haben leider ein Problem.
Die Menschen sind Sünder und die beten fremde Götzen an.
Also nachvollziehbar, weil sie ja auch ...
Also, ohne ihn zunahle zu reden, die haben ja auch lange nichts mehr gemacht.
Die errichten jetzt grosse Götzendenkmäler und es gibt übrigens noch Riesen ...
Ich weiss nicht, was da die Idee war.
Sie meinten, to be continued bei dem Entwurf. Die laufen jetzt halt auch noch rum. Also hier. Ich habe die Lösung hier. Eine Pandemie. Oh, sind Sie sicher? Ehrlich gesagt nicht. Machen Sie das erst. Das Problem mit den Riesen kriegen wir, glaube ich, in den Griff. Ja. Die Dinos sind mir alle zu weird jetzt. Die laufen mir zu langsam rum. Ja, die sind ein bisschen falsch abgebogen. Die sind komplett missraten. Zu oft falsch abgebogen, ja. Für die haben sie erstmal hier diese Lösung, Meteorit. Ah, das ist gut. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe beides draufgekriegt, Meteor und Asteroid, weil ich nicht genau weiß, was es nochmal war. Die Dinger, die auf die Erde fallen. So oder so heisst nicht Metroid. Meteorit, wenn dann. Ja, habe ich mich verschrieben. Aber ich bin auch allmächtig, von daher ist schon richtig, was da steht. Alles klar. Wie viel davon, 20, 30? Mal gucken, was reicht. Mal einen und dann schauen wir weiter. Erst mal mal einen. Mal einen, dann treffen wir uns morgen. Mal einen, dann mal gucken. Okay. Und ich glaube, Mexiko. Ich will Mexiko treffen. Mexiko kann weg. Ja?
Ich glaube, dass der ...
Schauen Sie mal, nehmen Sie mal den Stoffball,
ich dreh den Globus, Sie werfen und Sie gucken mal, wo es landet.
Ich werfe mal ein Metroid mal dahin, wo ich glaube.
Ah, Mexiko.
Gut, Mexiko, alles klar.
Okay, dann haben Sie ja gut gemacht.
Okay, alles klar.
Aber das mit der Pandemie können Sie sich ja mal aufheben.
Das behalten wir mal in der Hinterhand. Behalten Sie das mal in der Hinterhand. Dieser Podcast wurde lächerlich zeitgemäss und satirisch. Du meinst, die Pandemie ist eine Strafe Gottes? Mhm. Für? Für Ehebrechen. Okay. Sehr konkrete Strafe für Ehebruch.
Aber die Kommunikation hapert es halt manchmal auch, das wirklich zu kommunizieren.
Habe ich das denen nicht gesagt?
Es gab ja sieben Plagen damals, oder mehr?
13 Plagen? Weiß ich nicht.
Im Film Exodus jedenfalls, den ich tatsächlich geguckt habe, gab es Plagen. Der geht um Moses, heißt der Mann.
Und dann... Jomes.omis. Ist alles egal. Das ist alles scheiße. Hat der die Bibel überhaupt gelesen? Ja, Jomis und Ibrahom. Sorry, das... So jedenfalls fliegen, fahren Frösche durch die Luft. Fliegen Frösche auf kleinen Dreirädern. Auf kleinen Dreirädern, fahren Frösche. Wird das irgendwie aus einer anderen Sprache übersetzt? Oder wo kommen diese Ideen alle her? Ich spreche kein Hebräisch, bin ich jetzt ehrlich. Okay. Ich glaube, dass Frösche auf kleinen Fahrrädern auf dem Niedel fahren. Okay, und das soll eine Plage sein? Was ist da der ... Also jetzt, wir müssen es ja nicht übertreiben, aber das ist noch keine Plage. Da müssen wir ein bisschen hochdrehen den Nervigkeitscharakter. Und dann war Daniel doch rot aus Blut. Weil die Rinder sterben? Sind Sie sich sicher, dass Sie das richtig besetzt haben? Rot. Daniel wird rot. Heiss vielleicht? Oder was? Vielleicht heiss. Sie haben schon recht. Frösche fahren auf kleinen Dreirädern auf dem kochen heißen Nil. Okay, das ergibt wesentlich mehr Sinn. Das ergibt Sinn und da bestrafe ich die Menschen für. Für den grausigen Musikgeschmack. Gut, und wie teilen wir das den Menschen mit, dass genau diese zwei Plagen für den Musikgeschmacken? Das werden die sich schon erschließen können. Ich bin mir sicher, dass sie sich erschließen können. Denken Sie an die Sinnflut, die haben da wirklich im langen Dunkeln getappt. Sie haben immer noch Gebete rumliegen von der Sinnflut, lesen Sie die überhaupt? Es sind so viele. Da haben sich auch alle gefragt, was das sein soll. Gut. Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe. Mein Haus ist unter Wasser, Hilfe. Und auch wenn man das Wort Hilfe anfängt, muss man doch schon erahnen, man muss die Vergröße ja anpassen, dass man nicht am Ende das E so um den Rand kritzt. Ja, das stimmt, das ist ein Problem. Okay. Können Sie da zumindest auf das Gebet antworten? Nee, da muss man sich beim Mühe geben beim Beten. Da muss man sich beim Mühe geben beim Beten. Okay, ich würde von mir aus. Okay, also, plagenlos geht's, machen wir. Hast du irgendwen, den man fragen könnte, im Gotteshaus? Kirchen. Kennst du Pfarrer persönlich? Ich kenne einen Pfarrers Sohn, ja, ich kenne den Sohn eines evangelischen Pfarrers. Du kennst den Son of a Preacher Man? Ich kenne den Son of a Preacher Man. Und die waren aber auch weit unterwegs in Papua-Neuguinea und haben da missioniert. Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, wie das moderne Missionierungsarbeit aussieht. Ist aber Protestant und die waren da unterwegs. Und ja, der hat da immer direkt neben der Kirche gewohnt. Meine Frage ist, also schön, dass du die ganze Geschichte erzählst. Ich war dann oft im Gemeindehaus, wir haben da Warhammer Fantasy gespielt. Das klingt nicht göttlich. Die hatten zum Glück viele grüne Bücher, die konnten wir als Wälder verwenden.
Weil du hast dann so einen grossen Tisch, da hast du dann deine Armeen aufgestellt, so kleine Plastikfigürchen, die du anmalst. Und dann hast du so, grüne Bücher sind Wald, graue Bücher sind schwieriges Gelände, halbe Bewegungsreichweite und du darfst nicht marschieren. Und dann noch so Anhöhen oder so, wo du dann höhere Reichweite hast und über andere Einheiten rüberschießt. Und die Frage, die ich dir stellen möchte nach diesem ganzen Kladderadatsch ist, glaubst du, in Kirchen stehen verhältnismäßig viele grüne Bücher? Überdurchschnittlich viele. Wir haben tatsächlich bemerkt, meine Herren, viele grüne Bücher. Kann natürlich auch sein, dass die grünen Bücher am schlechtesten ankommen bei den Gläubigen. Grün ist doch die Farbe der Hoffnung. Na, das weiß ich nicht. Das müssen wir auch nochmal neu ordnen mit den Farben. Das glaube ich ist auch nicht mehr aktuell. Mittlerweile ist nicht mehr Grün Hoffnung, ne? Er hat jetzt nicht Gelb Hoffnung übernommen. Gelb ist Hoffnung jetzt. Weil Gelb hat ja gar nichts. Und Gelb dachte sich, Leute, ich bin einer der vier bekanntesten Farben, ich hab nichts. Gelb hat Emojis. Ja, das stimmt. Gelb hat viel, Gelb hat Freude. Pommes. Er hat auch Pommes, Sonne. Das Gelb hat schon viel. Grün hat nicht so viel, Grün ist oft die Basics. Grün ist so der Stiel einer schönen Pflanze. Grün ist neutral, das ist meine Aussage. Okay, Grün steht für Neutralität. Neutralität, absolute Neutralität. Aber hat dann der Son of a Preacher Man's Vater, hat der, ist der mal gekommen und hat gesagt, aber nicht nur die Orks spielen, hier, und dann hat er so einen Engel hingestellt und hat gesagt, ihr müsst doch Gottes Armee. Spielt doch mal mit Jesus. Spielt doch mal mit Jesus. Ja, aber Jesus hat nur Stärke zwei. Und Jesus hat nichts an. Ja, hier, sieht ihm was über. Nee, der hat sich da tatsächlich reitiert. Jesus hat nur Stärke zwei? Ganz cool. Warum hat Jesus eine Stärke zwei? Jesus hat eine Stärke zwei, Widerstandskraft drei. Das ist schlechter als ein normaler Mensch. Er hat doch diese Sonderkraft hier, er kann sich für alle umbringen. Ja, aber mein Gegner hat fünf Bannrollen, was soll ich dagegen machen? Okay, dann gebe ich dir hier Erzengel Michael. Och, Michael. Bewegungsgeschwindigkeit drei, der ist super langsam. Er hat Flügel, wer entsche fliegen, aber er ist trotzdem langsam. Das ist eh der Fehlschluss. Man sieht in so diesen Gemälden, in Kirchen denkt man immer Engel, dass die nur weil die Flügel haben sau schnell sind. Nein, die waren wahnsinnig langsam. Die sind so langsam geflogen, wie so, wenn man das kennt, maximal wie so ein grosser Geier, so ein behäbiger grosser Geier. So wirklich dann so, also Leute, ich pack's, macht's gut. Und dann bist du noch sieben Minuten, bis du auf zwei Meter Höhe bist. Und lange bis zum Himmel, das dauert echt ein Jahr. Und dann was da die Etikette, steht man da und winkt die ganze Zeit noch und ruft doch hinterher so Gesprächsenden, so, ja, ich sag ihr Bescheid ciao. Ja, grüß mir den Günther, ja. Genau, so wenn man so mit dem Zug noch nebenherläuft. Oder so. Aber ähnlich ist das Problem Christi Himmelfahrt. Christus Himmelfahrt, Jesu Himmelfahrt. Das war eine langsame Geschichte. So fucking langsam. Und die Aposteln standen daneben und dachten sich, meine Herren. Meine Herren. Hui, ui, ui. Und was sagt Jesus? Du hast dir ja überlegt, für die ersten eine Minute, wenn du da anfängst, in den Himmel zu fliegen, hast du noch ein paar coole Sprüche? Oh, ich kann von oben mein Haus sehen. Oh, Paulus, der Haarschnitt steht dir echt gut von hier oben. Oh, ich ... Halt so grosse Leutesprüche, da müsstest du jetzt eigentlich eingreifen. Das ist eigentlich genau dein Moment, Stefan. Du, das ist so eine Scheisse, glaube ich. Ich google jetzt, Engelgeschwindigkeit. Ach Quatsch, nein, die waren wirklich langsam. Du kannst ja ausrechnen, wie schnell ein Engel ist, wenn du dir die Spannweite des Flügels anschaust. Die waren super langsam. Was war so eine Spannweite eines Engels? Ja, kommt darauf an, wie viel Platz auf dem Bild ist, ne?
Und ob du Erzengel bist.
Oh ja, Erzengel, die kriegen noch mal ...
Die kriegen Metern dazu.
Erzengel Gabriel.
Ja.
Erzengel Michael.
Erzengel Raphael.
Lucifer.
Lucifer ist der gefallene Engel, ich weiß so viel, wegen Supernatural.
Ah, freut mich.
Nicht schlecht.
Und wenn ich mal irgendwann in der Kirche sitze, wird nach vorne auf die Bühne geholt. Spoiler, Spoiler, nicht Spoiler, nicht Spoilern, nicht Spoilern, sorry, la la la la, bei Erzengel Michael bin ich noch nicht, nicht Spoilern, ich bin erst mal Staffel drei. Aber wäre eigentlich eine geile Vorlesung, habe ich fast gesagt, Messe, wenn die, weil wenn die Supernatural spoilern sollten, dann müssten sie in so eine Richtung apokalyptische Reiter und so gehen, wo ich ehrlich gesagt in der Kirche mit ganz grossen Ohren sitzen würde. Ja, absolut. Meinen die Kirche gehen, Kirche gehen und mal gucken, was da so passiert? Nee, jetzt gerade nicht, aber so in perspektivisch, kann man doch mal wieder hin. Oder halt eine eigene Religion gründen. Ich glaube so, klar ist es natürlich cool mit dem Jahrtausende alten Geschichte und so und dass du halt in jedes Land gehst und sagst so, schon mal von Christus gehört? Ja, wir benutzen seine Zeitrechnung. Ach, ihr benutzt halt Zeitrechnung? Ach, das wusste ich gar nicht. Das ist ja nett. Ach so, ach so, aber ihr seid gar keine Christen, aber ihr benutzt trotzdem die Zeitrechnung. Die nervige Wespe, die viel zu weit um die Erde gebracht wurde.
Aha. Also wenn du sagst, wann hast du Geburtstag, benutzt du ... Sie sind nicht von hier. Also wenn du ... Sekunde. Wenn du sagst, wann hast du Geburtstag, benutzt du die Zeitrechnung nach Christi Geburt. Ja. Aha. Das ist ja spannend. Gut, das wollte ich nur wissen. Dann wünsche ich noch einen schönen Tag. Und dann langsame Autotür. Ach so. Ja, kann sein. Vielleicht lohnt sich das, nochmal neu anzufangen. In New York wollten wir ja mal in die Kirche gehen. Da wollten wir in so eine Gospelkirche. In so eine Gospelkirche gehen. Wir waren ja vor allem in Harlem. Und ich habe mal gedacht, zu hören, ich habe mal gedacht, gehört zu haben, dass ich mal einen Tweet gelesen habe, über die Kirchen in Haarlem, und dass da so richtig cool getanzt wird mit Gospel, Gospelchören. Aber ist das was für uns, dann auch so mitsingen und mittanzen und reinrufen, Praise the Lord, Jesus Christ, oh my God. Wenn du von der Bank gerutscht bist. Nee, weil ich ... Ich habe sowas gespillt von meinem Starbucks-Coffee. Oh my God! Jesus Christ! Und alle praise! He's right! That's right, baby! Praise the Lord! Ja, aber haben wir nicht gemacht, stattdessen haben wir Fruit Loops gegessen. Ja, wir haben Fruit Loops. Eine Menge, was eine andere Art von Gottesdienst ist, in meinen Augen. Gibt ja verschiedene, verschiedene Götter. Was machen die eigentlich? Sind die, also jetzt mal rar angenommen, was macht so ein Gott? Immer noch meine grösste Angst, dass die Recht haben. Niemand mehr an dich glaubt. Stell dir mal vor, die haben Recht. Und wir, im Gegensatz mit unserem Ave Maria, Maria und Jesu und Herakles. Die weirdesten Genitivä aller Zeiten. Fucking nervig. So, Christ Maria, Himmelfahrt und das, diese ganzen Quatsch. Also du stellst dir vor, du stirbst, Mehlexplosion, Stefan in der Küche, Weihnachtsbäckerei, will schöne Corsors backen, BAMP! Auf einmal explodiert, tot, du stehst vor Ra. Vor Ra und Anubis, vor Ra und Anubis, und die gucken dich an mit so einem, tja, jetzt. Mit ihren riesigen Tierköpfen und Anubis mit seinem Wellensittich slash Leguan-Kopf sagt sie mir dann so, im Ernst, Jesus, Jesus von Nazareth? Ich habe mir gedacht, das klingt Bullshit. Ich wusste immer schon, ich habe damals in der Kirche gesessen und gedacht, was wenn Anubis und Ra und so und tut ja nicht Amon mit seiner Maske. Und die dann auch so, nee, tut ja nicht Amon, hat auch einen anderen Gott von uns eingebietet, den es auch nicht gibt. Der hat sich noch einen sich so ... Genau, es gibt nur Anubis, es gibt nicht mal Ra. Und ich meine, stell dir mal vor, du denkst, du glaubst an Ra dein ganzes Leben, und dann sagst du so nah, so fucking nah. Das war so nah dran. Und jetzt an Anubis, oh nee. Das war so fucking nah dran. Und ich glaub, das ist even worse. Ich glaub, wenn du an Ra glaubst, aber Anubis ist der Macker da oben, dann bist du so leicht. Und dann sage ich so, Gott, ist das deutsche Wort für Anubis vielleicht. Ja, aber das stimmt eigentlich schon, weil ich glaube, je näher sich Dinge sind, desto größer der Hass. Ja, ja. Also Gelsenkirchen Dortmund. Genau, du hasst dein Nachbarland am meisten, du hasst dein Nachbarort am meisten. Ich glaube, für einen Anubisanbeter wäre ein Ra-Anbeter viel schlimmer als ein Buddhist. Das meine ich. Weil der sagt ja, ihr seid so weit weg.
Kommt her, ich trage diese lustigen
Windeln. Sorry, das ist wirklich
bescheuert, Reinkarnation
und okay. Aber das ist süss.
Das ist nett. Nee, komm her.
Kommt rein, das ist süss. Komm her, ich meine, ihr habt niemandem
was wehgetan, kommt her, passt schon.
Super, aber hier, von wegen
Ra, Hot Take, Sonnengott
oder was? Hot Take, Buddhisten haben niemandem wehgetan. Naja, sie wollten es zumindest nicht. Okay. Aber das wäre halt auch ein Schock, wenn du stirbst und dann hast du so einen Countdown und dann, japp, ganz recht, Reinkarnation ist real. Ja, fuck. Ist das eine Serie?
Ist das nicht The Good Place?
Nee, also Reinkarnation ist real.
Okay, pass auf, folgendes.
Reinkarnation ist real, aber du weißt nicht, was deine Leben davor waren.
Aber jetzt angenommen, Steve Jobs stirbt.
Und Steve Jobs wird reinkarniert in irgendeinem Kind. Tim Cook.
Also, oh Gott, ist fast genau das Gleiche. Genau,. Stimmt, nein, nein, warte mal, ganz kurz. Steve Jobs stirbt und ein Kind wird im selben Moment geboren, in dem Steve Jobs stirbt und Steve Jobs ist in dem Kind. Das Kind weiß es aber nicht. Und jetzt bist du Tim Cook und du musst dieses Kind finden, weil da Steve Jobs drin ist. Der die geheime Botschaft von Apple. Ja, der dann die Firma weiterführen kann, sozusagen. Und wenn das Kind irgendwann checkt, fuck, ich bin Steve Jobs, dann kommt auch all das Wissen zurück. Und dann, keine Ahnung, kannst du ja so ein Diktator-Führerkult sein, der Diktator stirbt und dann Nordkorea oder so, der Diktator stirbt. Und dann muss das ganze Land versuchen, das Kind zu suchen, das jetzt der Diktator, der reinkarniert ist. Aber das finde ich super. Und dann müssen wir das überall suchen. Kim Il-sung. Wir starten natürlich, die Serie startet natürlich bei dem Kind, das nicht weiss, dass es Kim Il-sung ist. Kim Il-sung ist. und das dann irgendwann in der Grundschule kontaktiert wird vom nordkoreanischen Geheimdienst.
Von Aliens.
Und das sich dann fragt, bin ich eigentlich, bin ich Paul, Paul oder bin ich Kim Il-sung?
Wann checkt denn Paul, dass er nicht Paul ist, sondern Kim Il-sung?
Wann checkt Paul das?
Weil, ja, checkt man, nein, du musst es, ja, keine Ahnung, das kannst du ja so zwischen zwei Staffeln erzählen. Paul ist auch unglücklich immer, weil Paul sieht sich nicht in diesem irdnischen Leben. Ja genau, Paul war schon immer ein bisschen anders. Bisschen Spoilt. Nee, die Serie fängt an, nach dem unerträglich langen Intro, fängt die Serie an mit Elternabend. Die Lehrerin sitzt vor den Eltern von Paule und sagt ... Und der Lehrer sagt so, jetzt hat ihr Kind schon wieder das südkoreanische Mädchen geschlagen. Aber kann es nicht sein, dass das südkoreanische Mädchen da ihn irgendwie geärgert hat oder so? Entschauen Sie hier, ich habe Zeichnungen, er hat nämlich das Millimeterpapier aus Mathematik, da ist ja gerade Geometrie. Sie brauchen übrigens, jetzt müssen Sie ein neues Geodreieck besorgen. Oh ja, schreibt es auf, Schatz. Schreibt es schnell auf, Schatz. Das meinen wir auch mit unabhängig langem Intro, also das ist dann Story sollte. Währenddessen Drehbuchautor, Production, Casting, Michael fucking Stephan Tietze. Es gehen sogar tatsächlich die Namen aus, so lange ist das Intro. Und dann ziehen sie sich das hier an, das sind die Zeichnungen und die machen uns grosse Sorgen. Das hat unser Paul gezeichnet. Paul hat diese, ja was ist es? Moment mal, ist das eine Atombombe? Ich glaube, das ist eine Atombombe, das sind Zeichnungen von Atombombe. Warte, wo hat der denn sowas her? Er kann es eigentlich nicht wissen. Wir haben es an unseren Physiklehrer gegeben und er hat gesagt, ja, daraus könnte man tatsächlich Atombomben bauen.
Und seitdem haben wir ihn nicht mehr gesehen.
Woher hat er dieses Wissen?
Cut to, Paule,
Wecker ist schon so eine grosse Bombe als Wecker,
er haut drauf und dann erstmal
richtig coole Gitarrenmusik.
Paule steht auf, springt auf
sein Skateboard, fährt die Treppe runter,
Paulus weht, fährt die Treppe
runter,
schaut sich in den Spiegel, dreht
Vielen Dank. Paulus steht auf, springt auf sein Skateboard, fährt die Treppe runter, Paulus wählt, fährt die Treppe runter, schaut sich in den Spiegel, dreht sich nochmal den Cap um, Tür auf, irgendwie die Mutter sagt, komm aber zum Essen wieder und Paulus so, fick dich Mutter und dann fährt er weg und dann fährt neben ihm, er fährt mit hoher Geschwindigkeit Skateboard, ein schwarzer Van. Genau, neben ihm ein schwarzer Van. Ein schwarzer Mercedes-Van, das ist nämlich die Kooperation, die wir haben. Genau, und Pauli denkt sich, was für eine scheiß Bonzen-Karren, interessiert mich nicht. Ja, zeig Mittelfinger. Mittelfinger, den häng ich ab, gibt richtig Gas und ist schneller. Aber nein, der Mercedes ist genauso schnell, mindestens, hält daneben dann an, also lass sie gleich schnell fahren. Fenster gehen langsam runter, da drin eine Reihe nordkoreanischer Gesichter. Und Paulus schaut sie an und plötzlich macht was Klick in ihm. Und sein Skateboard fällt und er kippt, fällt um. Er stürzt, oh, Schaden, Armbeuge, Schaden, Verletz. Schaden,ünf Schaden. Er ist jetzt auf 20 Lebenspunkten.
Unten rechts sind nämlich immer die Lebenspunkte eingezeichnet.
Wohingegen nordkameranischer Geheimdienst haben alle noch volle Lebenspunkte.
Alle noch volle Lebenspunkte.
Und volle Magazine auch. Super nervig auch, dass die immer darüber diese Balken haben.
Jeder Schauspiel hat sich immer so einen Balken.
Ja, es blockiert fast den ganzen Bildschirm.
Jedes Fakt.
Ganz merkwürdig.
Und diese Skills unten, super nervig.
Und in dem Moment, Paule, Crash-Zoom auf seiner Pupille, ohnmächtig. Ende Staffel 1. Ende Staffel 5. Noch nichts passiert, lange viel Intro. Dann pinzelt er, macht auf im Krankenhaus, im nordkoreaschen Krankenhaus und sie sagen, Herr Sung, und Paule sagt, ich bin ich bin Paulus. Mein Name ist Paulus. Aber er spricht jetzt koreanisch. Er spricht koreanisch. Er sagt, mich soll Paulus. Mich soll Paulus Schäfers. Und da müssen wir mal gucken. Da müssen wir mal schauen. Da machen wir mal so eine Kickstarter-Kampagne, ob es überhaupt weitergeht oder nicht. Aber bis dahin passt es. Da müssen wir mal gucken. Abgenommen? Das ist so beruhigend. Da müssen wir mal gucken. Müssen wir mal morgen früh in Ruhe. Ja, machen wir morgen. Das sind so tolle Sätze. Ja, super. Das mache ich morgen früh in Ruhe. Richtig, richtig gut. Das geht sich schon aus. Das passt schon. Müssen wir mal gucken, dass wir mal schauen, dass wir mal hingucken. Ja, müssen wir halt mal gucken dann, ne? Nie wieder. Noch nie hat jemand geguckt.
Noch nie hat jemand die Action geguckt. Es wurde noch nie geguckt. Man hat das gesagt, dann das Thema war begraben und nie wieder gesehen. Das Verhältnis von mal gucken zu tatsächlich geguckt ist gravierend schlecht. Ist so schlecht, dass man sich Gedanken machen muss, wenn man das sagt, dass man eigentlich aktiv die Zukunft beeinflusst. Das ist nicht beeinflusst. Shoutout, wenn ihr da draußen schon mal gesagt habt, ja, müssen wir mal gucken, und dann aber auch tatsächlich geguckt habt, meldet euch. Ich glaube, das sind sehr beschränkte Menschen. Also Zahl, Anzahl an Menschen. Das sind sehr beschränkte Menschen. Apropos beschränkt, wir haben ja letzte Woche eine Beschränkung auferlegt der Kunstwelt. Ich hab keine Erinnerung, ich habe nie Erinnerung. Das ist mein Lieblingsmoment, wenn ich über die Aktion der letzten Woche rede, die in der Regel deine Idee ist. Ja. Du haust immer irgendeine Idee raus, die Leute schicken mir die Sachen ein und nächste Woche, was, was, erinnere ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr. Ne, was war die Aktion von letzter Woche? Ich weiß nicht, habe ich behauptet, dass man Bilder zu tönen machen kann. Nee, Stefan, jetzt erst mal im Ernst. Was war die Aktion letzte Woche? Was haben wir aufgerufen, was die Leute uns schicken sollen? Macht das jetzt nie das Wieso on the spot? Haben wir letzte Woche, Moloch war vor ein paar Wochen, ne? Schon lange her, Moloch ist schon lange vorbei. Aber das ist ja in Moloch, sag ich es jetzt plötzlich. Ich habe auch erst ein paar Mal ... Ich erfah, nicht ablenken. Was war die Aktion letzte Woche? Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Sag grob das Thema, Kunst hast du gerade schon gesagt. Film, ja, Film. Film? Die sollen Film gucken. Die Leute sollen einen Film gucken. Nee, aber nah dran, was kann man noch? Entweder man guckt ihn oder ... Man leiht ihn aus. Die Aktion war, jeder soll sich mindestens einen Film leihen. Das war die Podcast-Ufot-Leihaktion zur Unterstützung von Videotheken. Man kann Filme gucken, man kann sie noch. Ja. Man kann Filme gucken. Damit man sie gucken kann, müssen sie davor, ja, gekauft werden. Ja, aber noch davor. Muss man sie kennen, damit man sie kaufen kann. Jeder sollte seine Lieblingsfilme aufschreiben. Alle sollten... Die müssen gemacht werden erst mal. Ah, die draußen, die sollten Filme machen. Genau, und zwar... Och Gott, ey Stefan, Geister, wir haben letzte Woche ausgerufen zum grossen GIF-Kurzfilmfestival. Ah ja, na klar, das GIF-Festival. Das grosse GIF-Festival. Die Leute sollten kurze GIFs einschicken, und zwar zum gross und zwar zum großen Giftfestival. Und ich sag mal so viel, es wurden schon sehr viele coole Sachen eingeschickt. 50 Frames, Leidenschaft in 50 Frames war der Untertitel. Leidenschaft, das bedeutet in 50 Frames. Und wir haben schon einige Sachen bekommen. Wir geben euch jetzt noch mal die Chance, noch mal weitere einzuschicken. Und dann machen wir auf Instagram das große Kurzfilm-Live-Giftfestival. Sind wir da im Anzug und verleihen die besten Sachen? Können wir machen, weißt du nicht in 20 Minuten schon direkt vergessen hast. Schreib schnell auf, sonst machen wir es nicht. Müssen wir mal gucken. Wir werden dort auf Instagram alle eingesandten Kurzfilme zeigen und es ist auf jeden Fall kurz, weil die sind wirklich kurz und knackig, 50 Frames ist fast nichts, also wirklich kurz geprinzelt und du hast es verpasst. 50 Frames in zwei Sekunden noch was. Ja, aber das ist wirklich wenig. Also kurz mal hup und vorbei. War das ein Film? Und vorbei, schon weg. Kannst du mir einen zeigen? Nein. Wie? Nein, ich werde alle vorbehalten, denn du bist die Jury, du kennst dich aus, du warst in Cannes und du musst die bewerten und am Ende den Preis verleihen. Stimmt, ich war in Cannes.
Richtig.
Oder?
Ja, du warst in Cannes.
Du hast Shrimp gegessen, meintest du.
Ah ja, das war cool.
Ich habe kein gutes Gedächtnis.
Deswegen Fotoalben.
Ich glaube, Fotoalben sind echt nützlich,
weil man wirklich sagt, ich war, stimmt, ich war in Barcelona.
Bardo.
Ich war da, unser Urlaub inadeau. Ich erinnere mich. Das hättest du sonst komplett vergessen. Das war der schönste Urlaub in Badeau. Richtig, richtig schön. Wir hatten so eine gute Zeit in Badeau. Ja, und als wir da an dieser großen Seilbahn hingen und vom Hotel bis auf den Strand fahren konnten. Super, oder? Richtig toll. Du hast sogar versucht, Wakeboard zu fahren. Du wolltest über diesen kleinen Strandabschnitt drüber springen, weil da gab es so eine Landzunge, eine Landzunge direkt ins Meer rein, wo die Leute darauf gespielt haben und du hast gesagt, hey, ich werde da mit dem Wakeboard fahren, wenn genug Wind ist und einmal über die Landzunge drüber springen. Und wir haben alle gesagt, Stefan, vergiss es, das schaffst du nicht, das schaffst du nicht. Wir waren wir, wir und die Jungs. Wir und die Jungs, Marianne und Henriette waren dabei. Und du, zack, erster Tag, wir haben noch gesagt, komm, lass uns erst mal auspacken, noch einen schönen Aperol Spritz trinken. Und du warst direkt Badehose am Strand, Wakeboard sofort in die Welt. Was hast du denn mal Aperol Spritz getrunken? Und ja, am Ende hast du es dann auch versucht, drüber zu springen. Das ist wie dieses GIF, was es gibt, dieses Meme. So ein Prank war das damals, wo so ein Typ so eine Katze in der Hand hatte, meine ich, oder war es ein Huhn? Und dann war da... Warte, warte, warte, warte, warte. Das fällt auseinander. Nee, dann war da so eine alte Frau im Supermarkt. Und dann haben die da so hinter sie gegriffen. Das kenne ich, ja. War das ein Huhn oder eine Katze? Das war ein Kind. Das war ein kleines Kind sogar. Ja, aber so fühle ich mich gerade. Das so, so fühle ich mich gerade. Wie diese alte Frau. Ja, das war ein Prank. Also die sind zu einer älteren Frau hingegangen und haben gesagt, Entschuldigung, Sie haben da was im Haar. Und dann stand hinter der Frau jemand, der ein Kind gereicht hat. Und die haben so getan, als würden sie aus den Haaren ein Kleinkind rausziehen. Und sie hat so eine Oma ein Kind rausgezogen. Und dann war so ein Zoom auf die Oma. Die war so maximal verwirrt einfach. Die war komplett nüberschuldig. Ja, und die denkt doch so, ich bin offensichtlich nicht mehr zu gebrauchen. Ich kann jetzt sterben. Ich meine, bei alten Leuten ist es fast ein bisschen gemein. Finde ich auch so gemein. Weil die ja wirklich denken, das war's das jetzt, war's das? Ich habe manchmal schon so Momente, wo ich denke, das war's. Ja. Meine geistige Kapazität ist beendet. Das war gerade ein bisschen so wie dieses GIF, weil ich habe auch das Gefühl, ich habe meine Gehirnkapazität ist geschrumpft auf ein Minimum. Ja. Ich kann mich auf eine Sache konzentrieren, zwei Sachen kriege ich nicht mehr hin.
Und was letzte Woche im Podcast gesagt wurde, ihr habt keine Ahnung, ihr schreibt mir häufig Sachen. Ich weiß nicht, worauf die sich beziehen. Ja, ja, auch auf Twitter hat jemand geschrieben, wie heißt denn die Melodie, die Stefan da gepfiffen hat und ich einfach wahrscheinlich Jurassic Park. Und er schreibt, ja, es war Jurassic Park. Aber keine Ahnung, welche Folge, welcher Timecode, nichts, aber... Gott sei Dank war es Jurassic Park. Ich meine, ich kenne Stefan, sein Repertoire ist nicht so groß. Und das Lustige ist, wenn heute bei der Folge jemand gefragt hätte, wäre es wieder Jurassic Park gewesen. Natürlich. Das Gute ist, wir bleiben uns halt auch treu. Ja. Wir haben drei Referenzen. Gut, sich treu bleiben heißt halt auch, nicht weiter zu bleiben. Wir entwickeln uns maximal wenig weiter. Deswegen, ich bin auch ein Feind von Keep It Real. Ich hasse Don't keep it real. Keep it fake. Keep it fake, keep it unreal, reinvent yourself. Forget who you were yesterday, please.
Forget who you were, keep it fake.
Please.
Be who you want to be, even if you are not.
Yes, don't be who you think you are, be who you think you can be.
Cool. Gut, dass es sich nicht reint. Das kann man sich merken.
Nee, aber don't keep it real.
Kann man nochmal ein Sprichwort erfinden? Ich würde gerne ein Sprichwort erfinden und das rausgeben in die Welt. Das ist eine spannende Szene, ich verfolge das gerade intensiv, denn unsere liebgegrüssten Podcast-Kollegen von Drinnis, die versuchen gerade ein Sprichwort zu etablieren. Und ich würde sagen, wir versuchen die zu unterstützen. Anstatt dass wir uns unser Konkurrenz-Sprichwort aufbauen, können wir die gerne unterstützen.. Ich finde eher gut, wenn andere Dinge machen, die man selber machen wollte. Genau, unterstützen ist immer leichter. Du kannst in der Schule dann dich kurz nach dem Streber melden und sagen, ah, wollte ich auch sagen, wollte ich auch sagen. Aber an der Stelle nochmal, vielen Dank für diesen tollen Wortbeitrag, das hat mir gerade richtig gut gefallen. Richtig toll, ich finde, du hast es toll formuliert, so gut hätte ich es nicht formulieren können, aber die Gedanken ähnlich. Und Chris und Julia vom Drinnis-Podcast, fantastischer Podcast, kann man... Übrigens ist er nominiert für den deutschen Podcastpreis. Ja, grossartig. Also hört den Podcast. Hört den einfach. Was macht ihr noch hier? Was macht ihr hier? Und die versuchen das Sprichwort zu etablieren, wer abbeisst, muss auch kauen. Wer abbeisst, muss auch kauen. Finde ich ein tolles Sprichwort. Ich habe es tatsächlich schon mal, also natürlich nicht mit anderen Leuten, ich spreche nicht mit anderen Leuten, aber man hat ja so einen inneren Monolog. Und da habe ich mich letztens schon dabei erwischt, wo ich mir dachte, wer abbeist, muss auch kauen. Also wenn du dir was selber einbrockst. Es ist aber im Prinzip einfach, wer A sagt, muss auch B sagen. Im Grunde schon, aber halt weniger abstrakt, weniger algebraisch. Es ist mehr geometrisch, es ist mehr kulinarisch. Die Erwachsenenform von diesem Kindersprichwort, wer A sagt, muss auch B da, wer 1 sagt, muss auch 2 sagen.
Ja, das stimmt schon. Mir wärst du ein bisschen zu nah dran. Aber ich bin trotzdem völlig bereit, das voll zu backuppen. Ja, wer den Regenbogen will, muss auch den Regen hinnehmen. So, das ist schon in der Tradition dieser Sprichwörter. Aber ich finde, es ist kurz und knackig, wer abbeist, muss auch kauen, super, super kurz. Kauen kann manchmal super anstrengend sein. Wer abbeist, muss auch kauen. Man sagt es auch gerne, es hat diesen schönen Punkt, es endet schön. Und jeder, glaube ich, hat schon mal das Erlebnis gemacht, du beisst einfach zu viel ab, musst kauen, vielleicht in Gesellschaft, du hast irgendwie ein Riesenstück abgebissen, kriegst es nicht hin, du denkst dir, wie viel Platz ist in meinem Mund, was ist der Gaumen, wohin geht's, bist Munddach. Und du weißt nicht, wohin damit. Das Munddach.
Das Munddach, ja. Gaumen ist Munddach.
Im Grunde schon.
Ceiling.
Ceiling of the mouth.
Mittlerweile sind wir schon so weit, dass wir nicht mal mehr die Mintry-Maten-Gags hinbekommen,
sondern sie nur noch grob skizzieren,
nur noch einzelne Wörter aus den
Gags sagen. Das Gute ist,
wenn ihr, wie ich, kein gutes Gedächtnis habt,
denkt ihr manchmal, ihr werdet ein Genie,
weil ihr Dinge sagt, die so mindblowing sind,
und dann sagt Florian euch, jetzt kriegen wir im Haar.
Mittlerweile sind wir so faul, wir kriegen demitischen Martin-Gags nicht mehr hin,
und man denkt, fuck, ich hatte die ganze Zeit ein Kind im Haar.
So fühle ich mich gerade. Aber kann passieren. Das war mein Kind im Haar. So fühle ich mich gerade.
Aber kann passieren.
Das war mein Kind im Haar.
Ja, das kann schon passieren.
Weil ich dachte gerade, ich bin ein fucking Genie.
Glaubst du, von dir laufen schon Kinder in der Welt, ohne dass du es weisst?
Ich glaube, Leute ziehen die ganze Kinder aus meinem Haar und die laufen noch rum in der Welt.
Und irgendwann fällt es auf mich zurück, weil ich habe geklaut offensichtlich. Wenn dich so ein Zweijähriger anschreiben würde und sagen, du bist mein Vater. Konkret glaube ich das nicht. Nee? Also, also, nee, ich glaube nicht. Was wird sich ändern? Schwierig. Du musst halt woanders hinziehen, du musst wegziehen in die Karibik. Ich muss
in die Karibik ziehen. Nach Barracuda, vielleicht an die Barracuda-Bar. Ich glaube, Barracuda ist
nichts. Ich glaube, Barracuda klingt wie Karibik, deswegen sagt man das. Ich glaube, Barracuda,
ist Barracuda nicht ein Fisch? Nein, der Fisch wurde nach der Strandbar benannt. Ich glaube,
es geht alles bei der Surferkultur los. Alles war erstmal eine Surferkultur.
Ich glaube auch, erst haben Surfer eine Haifischkette getragen und danach wurde der Fisch überhaupt erst entwickelt.
Darauf will ich nämlich hinaus. Ich glaube, Barakuda hat keinen Ursprung.
Ich glaube, da beißt sich die Katze in den eigenen Schwank.
Am Anfang war das Wort. Wir wissen immer noch nicht, welches Wort. Die Bibel schweigt sich aus. Das Wort Barakun. Welches? Welches Wort denn? Aber ja, stimmt schon. Am. Am? Am Anfang war das Wort. Also am. Am Anfang. Am Anfang war das Wort. Ach so, okay. Jetzt wird es spitz für dich. Muss die gesamte Theologie noch mal neu gedacht werden?
Die gesamte zweitausendjährige Kirchengeschichte?
Ich hätte mal so eine Bibel,
wo der erste Buchstabe ganz
gross geschrieben ist. Das kennt man
auch, manchmal kennt man das von Büchern.
Ja, nämlich an Prokrastinieren.
Du wirst halt erst mal einfach
nee, der erste Buchstabe
muss schon schön sein.
Und dann kommst du halt nicht zum Rest des Texts. Wird halt dann nichts. Wie heisst das nochmal? Wie heissen diese riesen Buchstaben nochmal? Prokrastinat. Prokrastinat. Toren. So nennt man das einfach. Prokrastinatoren. Ja, weil früher Mönche halt einfach, boah, wie fange ich jetzt an? Aber mad respect, dass sie schon wussten, mit welchem Anfangsbuchstaben das, deren Buch beginnt. Das ist sehr hilarisch. Das könnte auch eine Hilfe sein. Die Vorstellung. Und dann malt man ein bisschen rum. Ja genau, du hast das erste Buchstabe. Vielleicht haben die auch Zettel vorbereitet, wo jede einzelne Buchstabe einmal ist. Das ist prokastinat. Und dann einfach jeder Mönch kriegt eins ausgeteilt. So leben als Mönch, glaube ich, war schon geil. Man kann das ja jetzt auch machen. Du kannst jetzt theoretisch dieses Weitere. Ja, aber das ist ja was anderes, wenn du der Einzige bist, der schreiben kann. Und die einzigen Bücher im Land stehen bei dir im Regal. Und ansonsten hat niemand was. Und du bist der Einzige und schreibst es ab. Klar, alles bei Kerzenlicht, nervig. Du musst alles bei Kerzenlicht machen, du hast keine so schöne halogenen Röhre. Bei Kerzen oder Tageslicht. Oder Tageslicht, ja. Aber auch da nervig, oh, ich habe letztens einen Artikel gelesen, in dem es darum ging, dass früher früher anscheinend die Menschen in der Nacht noch mal aufgewacht sind. Was? Dass es völlig normal war, dass Menschen in der Nacht noch mal aufwachen für eine Stunde
und sich dann noch mal hinlegen und dann den Rest schlafen.
Was machen sie denn in der Stunde? Ganz verschiedene
Dinge. Also
es wurde so ein bisschen
angedeutet, was da der Sinn dahinter sein können,
dass man irgendwie nach den Kindern schaut oder dass man
guckt, ob noch alle da sind, nach Kranken
schaut oder ob man, dass man
anderen Leuten auch was klauen kann in der
Zeit. Hier stand auch in dem Artikel. Es geht sehr weit auseinander. Es fängt total schön an. Also dass die Kumpel-Durzonen sich dachte, nee, nee, wir lassen die nachts aufwachen, damit die sich was klauen können. Damit die sich beklauen. Und dann haben die gesagt, ja, warte mal, sind die, bei denen man klaut, dann nicht auch wach zu der Zeit? Aber es klingt eigentlich nach einem schönen Ritual. Nachts wachen alle kurz auf, beklauen sich. Und dann gibt es diesen einen berühmten Tag, wo alle sich wieder das klauen, das alle wieder haben, womit sie angefangen haben. Und dann rufen alle Hossa, Hossa! Und dann können die nicht mehr einschlafen, weil es zu laut ist. Also nicht ideal. Das ist die Sommersonnenwende, das nennt man heute die Sommersonnenwende. Viele Kulturen haben auch meditiert in der Zeit oder über ihre Träume nachgedacht, die sie bis dahin hatten, und haben dann für bessere Träume gebetet, wenn sie sich dachten, der erste Traum, irgendeine krude Geschichte von so einem Jungen, der eigentlich Kim Il-sung ist und irgendwie mit Leuten, Quatsch, schauen wir das und was irgendwie besser weitergeht im nächsten Teil. Manche von denen haben über bessere Tag-Nacht-Rhythme nachgedacht in der Sturne, haben sich überlegt, sollen wir nicht einfach wachstags überschlafen. Aber anscheinend hat sich das verändert durch die Beleuchtung, dass Städte immer heller geworden sind und immer mehr künstliches Licht es gab, dass die Leute dadurch, dass irgendwie das nicht mehr passiert ist, dass sie nachts aufgewacht sind. Ganz merkwürdige Theorien, ganz wenig wissenschaftliches Fundament, aber spannende Idee. Aber glaubst du, dass sich die Bildschirme, auch so dieses blaue Licht und so, künstliches Licht generell, alles jetzt verschoben haben? Weil ich habe das Gefühl, wenn ich jetzt so eine freie Woche habe, wo ich am nächsten Tag keine Termine habe, dann ist bei mir eigentlich kein, dann habe ich keinen Tag-Nacht-Rhythme mehr. Dann sagt mir der Tag, du sagst mir gar nichts mehr, Tag. Richtig. Ich lasse mich von der Sonne hier, dieser feurige Ball am Himmel, der seit Jahrtausenden die Menschen versklavt, nicht mehr! Nee, du kannst machen, was du willst, aber ich gehe ins Bett, wenn ich will. Ich bin ein erwachsener Mensch, Sonne. Aber jetzt, Harry, noch mal ganz kurz zum leidigen, leidigen Thema Evolution. Ja. Weil du sagst es ja selber, dieses blaue Licht, dass Laptops und Handys ausstrahlen, das hat ja irgendwie so Special-Kräfte und das Auge denkt, wow, es ist helllichter Tag, ich kann jetzt nicht schlafen. Ich will nie wieder schlafen. Kriegen wir das denn evolutionär hin, dass das weggeht? Weil jetzt müssten wir eigentlich sagen, das geht ja nie weg, weil es ist ja nie ein Fortpflanzungsvorteil. Ich muss noch mal meine leidige, leidige Evolutionsthese jetzt raushauen. Wir als Menschen haben die Evolution überwunden. Du kannst die nicht überwinden, die geht ja immer weiter. Du kannst die nicht überwinden. Solange nicht alle Menschen sich fortpflanzen, wird es Evolution geben. Ich erkläre dir noch mal, wie Evolution funktioniert. Es ist wirklich leidig. Ja, du hast aber angefangen, okay? Okay. Eisbären, du musst jetzt einmal gut durch. Wer abbeist, muss auch kauen. Wer abbeist, muss auch kauen, wer A sagt, muss auch Eisbären sagen. Eisbären haben irgendwann überlebt, es ist eine Mutation, normale Bären, Bären, irgendwann wurde einer durch eine Mutation in den Gegenstamm. Ja, ich weiß, wie das funktioniert, worauf willst du hinaus? Weiss, der hat überlebt, weil Fortpflanzung einfach keine Fressfeinde mehr, easy. Menschen, wir Menschen, wir haben solche Feinde nicht mehr, wir haben auch nicht dieses ausgewählte Fortpflanzungsding mehr. Bei uns, wir haben das überwunden. Die Menschheit hat das überwunden. Wenn wir deine Narreteile gerade mal kurz ernst nehmen, dann könnten wir sagen, wie liess es sich die Evolution aufhalten? Ja, eigentlich nur so, wenn man sagt, jeder Mensch muss sich, erst wenn sich jeder Mensch fortpflanzt, mit dem gleichen Verhältnis, wenn jedes Paar zwei Kinder kriegt und sich jeder Mensch fortpflanzt, dann gibt es keine Evolution mehr, weil dann gibt es ja keine Selektion mehr. Aber bis zu dem Punkt, wenn manche Kinder, manche haben drei Kinder, manche gar keine, also werden die Eigenschaften, die die hatten, die die drei Kinder kriegen, fortgegeben und gibt es häufiger in der Population als die, die sich nicht fortpflanzen. Das ist absolut lächerlich. Ich habe erledigt nicht geantwortet auf deine dusselige Frage. Ja, du hast keine Antwort gegeben. Ob wir Menschen, ganz kurz, Herr Will, dann müssen Sie mir jetzt auch mal ausreden lassen. Ja, ich würde Ihnen gerne zuhören, wenn man Ihnen zuhören könnte, weil eine Dummheit jagt die nächste von Ihnen. Wenn wir blaues Licht als blöd wahrnehmen, nicht mehr schlafen können, dann ist das okay, passiert, wir werden es nicht überwinden. Ja, aber wie geht es in die DNA rein? Die DNA hat damit gar nichts zu tun. Ja, aber die vererbt man doch weiter. Aber sie pflanzen sich doch nicht extra mit einer Frau fort, die das nicht hat. Nein, ihnen ist das egal. Sie sagen, es gibt jetzt irgendwelche Dating-Plattformen, auf denen man die Frauen und Männer findet, die zufällig die Mutation haben, dass sie nicht von blauem Licht beeinflusst werden. Das ist ja genau mein Punkt. Und die sollen dann Kinder haben, wie blöd oder was? Was sind das denn für lächerliche Vorstellungen, die wir haben? Wir als Menschheit haben das überwunden. Wir pflanzen uns nicht fort, weil jemand XY-Trieb hat oder hier besonders ist oder diese blaue Licht nicht mehr war.. Ja, aber man wählt doch trotzdem seinen Fortpflanzungspartner aus. Das ist nicht mein Wort. Als ob der Eisbär weiss, der Eisbär sagt doch auch nicht, oh, jetzt pflanze ich mich mit der etwas weisseren Bären da bevor. Nein, aber landen Sterbbarhaus. Sondern das Weiss ist ja unbewusst. Weiss ist Survival of the fittest, der angepassteste an seiner Umgebung.
Deswegen überleben doch die Weissen. Aber es überleben doch nicht die Frauen und die Männer mit den besseren Augen. Okay, gut. Also was Sie sagen, ist die Menschen, die am meisten von dem blauen Licht gestört werden, schlafen weniger, sind unproduktiver, finden keinen Partner, pflanzen sich nicht fort und sterben langsam aus. Und die, die eher weniger davon beeinflusst werden, sind aktiv, schlafen, pflanzen sich viel fort und dann wird das immer mehr in der Population. Dann wird es genau. Leider Gottes hat das aber nicht so einen Einfluss auf die Menschheit. Und wenn ich ein bisschen länger aufbehebe wegen blauen Lichtsäden. So, und jetzt müssen Sie mich mal ausreden lassen. Ja, jetzt schon langsam kommen wir mal an den Punkt. So, jetzt kommen wir nicht mal an den Punkt, der wird spannend. Sie haben haben ja recht, hat aber dieses blaue Licht nicht so einen krassen Einfluss
auf mein Leben? Nein, gar nichts.
Auch meine Weisheitszähne haben auch keinen Einfluss
mehr auf mein Leben. Das heißt,
mir werden die jetzt einfach rausgenommen,
tatsächlich übrigens nächsten Monat. Oh, das wird eine lustige Folge.
Das wird eine lustige Folge. Wenn du völlig betreut bist.
Wenn ich noch so druck bin auf so Morphium.
Und dann
auch keinen Einfluss mehr auf mein Leben, deswegen wird es einfach
weitergegeben. Es werden die rausgenommen, aber trotzdem ist ja beim Erbgut noch meine scheisse Weisheitszähne drin. Meine Trichterbrust. Tiere werden damals totgetrampelt worden mit Trichterbrüsten. Die können doch nicht weglaufen vor Fressfeinden, da brauchen sie gar nichts dazu lachen. Trichterbrustiger, die können doch nicht die berühmten T-T's, die Trichterbrustiger, die können doch nicht vor Feinden weglaufen, nur keine Kondition. Trichterbrüst ist drücken aufs Herz. Aber Quatsch, wenn die T-T's Trichterbrüste haben, heisst das doch nicht, dass es notwendigerweise ein Nachteil sein muss. Natürlich, Trichterbrüst ist ein Nachteil, drücken aufs Herz. Die Tatsache, dass du eine hast, heisst, zeigt doch, dass es kein Nachteil war, sonst gäbe es das ja nicht mehr. Nein, wir als Menschen, wir haben diese Eitelkeit, uns nicht mit Trichterbrüsten, brüstigen Menschen vorzupflanzen, überwunden.
Okay, aber mit wem pflanzen wir uns denn dann fort? Es muss ja Eigenschaften geben, die dann irgendwie weitergegeben werden.
Mit Leuten, die gut zweipen können, die gut auf Tinder schön zweipen können den ganzen Tag, die pflanzen sich fort.
Jeder, den ich kenne, hat Eltern mit Schwächen. Sowas wie Herzprobleme. Das hat sich persönlich gemeint. Schon persönlich gemeint. Sowas wie Herzprobleme. Wen sprichst du genau an? Ich spreche alle, die ich kenne an. Alle? Ja, alle Eltern haben Schwächen. Da hat niemand auch nur einen starken Papa oder Mama. Und da gucke ich auf euch alle. Und die sind alle crap, die Eltern. Alle haben Schwächen, haben Herzprobleme, haben Neurodermitis, haben Diabetes, Alzheimer. Ist alles in unserem Erbgut drin. Ja. Das kennen wir auch spätestens aus der Genfolge, wo ich meinen Gentest gemacht habe. Richtig. Alle haben das. Warum gibt es diese ganzen Sachen noch, wenn Evolution funktioniert noch? Ja, aber... Was mir auch aufgefallen ist, die Städte, die in Italien sind, nennen wir beim... Nein, stopp, stopp, stopp, wir hören auf. Wir brechen die Folge hier ab. Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher. Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher. Ich glaube nur, dass wir Evolution überwunden haben. Bin ich ganz ehrlich. Nein, das geht nicht. Du kannst die Evolution nicht überwinden. Die Evolution geht immer weiter. Nur weil du nicht weisst, nach welchen Merkmalen momentan selektiert wird, heisst das nicht, dass die Evolution aufhört.
Das ist mir schon klar.
Wir werden erst in tausend Jahren erfahren, ach, jetzt haben alle sechs Finger, anscheinend gab es irgendwelche weirden Merkmale, die da transportiert wurden, dass alle sechs Finger haben. Oder vier. Oder einen. Einen grossen.
Einen grossen?
Einen Finger? Oder an einer Hand?
So ein Fäustling. Kennt man ja diese geilen Handschuhe. Man hat einen Daumen und dann so eine flache Hand. Oder es wird asymmetrisch. Du hast an einer Hand ein und an der anderen Hand neun.
Dann bist du der beste Gitarrist der Welt, weil du mit der linken Hand ganz komplexe Akkorde greifen kannst und der rechte, da reicht dir ein dicker Daumen, um Powerchords zu ballern. Thunderstruck die ganze Zeit. Ja, das wird dann schwierig. Das wird nervig, nervige Zeit. Und stehen ganz, ganz düstere Zeiten voraus. Ich meine nur, ich meine nur, ich meine nur. Um uns persönliches Ende zu finden, ich bin ja voll an der Meinung, und natürlich wird weiter selektiert und wir haben die Evolution nicht überwunden, wie ich die ganze Zeit behaupte, das war nur fürs Zitat.
Das stand aber in ihrer Bauchbinde die ganze Zeit.
Ja, das war fürs Zitat.
Da stand Stefan Tietze in Klammern, denkt, dass die Evolution überwunden wurde.
Das habe ich ihm nur gesagt, um Gehör zu finden.
Was ich ihm eigentlich sagen wollte, ist, ich glaube, wir werden diese Schwäche nicht los, von blauem Bildschirm wachgehalten zu werden.
Gut.
Aber das ist eine gute Frage, also da müssen wir mal drüber reden. Wie kriegen wir das hin? Ist das unser Projekt? Drenis versucht, ein neues Sprichwort zu etablieren, das Podcast UFO versucht, die DNA so zu steuern und die Evolution zu steuern, damit uns blaues Licht nicht vom Schlafen abhält. Mal schauen, wer mehr Erfolg hat. Pass auf, ich finde es gar nicht schlecht, so ein utopisches Ziel zu haben. Ein krasses Ziel. Wir werden krebslos zum Beispiel. Das kann ja auch das Ziel sein. Wir werden erst mal Aids los. Ich bin Aids los geworden. Aber du musst jetzt so viele Kinder kriegen, wie es nur irgendwie geht. Weil du hast die Mutation in dir, dass du kein Aids haben kannst. Wenn du jetzt ganz viele Kinder hast, dann wird irgendwann die Menschheit von Aids befreit sein, weil alle immun sind. Also los geht's, Stefan. Die Uhr tickt auch ein bisschen. Die Uhr tickt. Aber hast du mal über Samenspende nachgedacht? Weil du hast ja offensichtlich einen richtig derbguten DNA-Set. Nein, hab ich nicht. Du bist auch immun gegen Aids. Ja, aber dann hast du dann trichterbrüchtige Erdlinge, die zu gross gewachsen sind, aber kann Aids bekommen. Aids ist doch auch gar nicht mehr gefährlich. Weiß ich nicht. Grosses Nervchen Flugzeugen. Ich würde dich motivieren, mal bei einer Samenbank vorbeizuschauen. Generell hätte ich auch da mal Lust auf den Prozess. Einfach mal den Prozess mitzumachen. Und kriegt man nicht ein Schweinegeld? Sie kriegen ein Schmullheftchen, einen Plastikbecher und ein Schweinegeld. Schweinegeld. Ja, vielleicht wirklich, ich weiß nicht. Wäre ich gut. Völlig kann ich mir mal überlegen. Falls ihr ein Kind von Chef und Tietze haben wollt, dann schreibt es an zentraler Podcast. Wir haben literweise noch rumstehen im Kühlschrank. Da kriegen wir... Wir werden das nicht los. Wir werden das nicht los. Verkauft im Merch-Shop, klickt euch einfach durch. Alter, das wäre so lustig, wenn das der Merch... Ist das verboten? Wenn das der fucking Merch-Shop wäre. Stell dir mal vor, so eine Rock-, die Stones hätten im Merch-Shop literweise Sterne. Stimmt schon, ich meine, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du irgendein Pärchen will, Kinder kriegen, aber es funktioniert nicht, dann zu sagen, ja, dann hol ich mir Sperma von Stefan Tietze. Aber im The Who Fan-Shop, die machen das doch. Ist das verboten, seinen eigenen Samen zu verkaufen? Ja, vor allem, ich habe aber auch so, jetzt werde ich ein bisschen grössenwahnsinnig gerade merke ich, wie viele Nachfahren kann man kriegen? Ja, unendlich viele. Ja, ne? Du brauchst ja nur ein Spermium. Ich will das in der Zukunft, wie heutzutage alle sagen, oh, ich stamm irgendwie von Genghis Khan ab, will ich das alle irgendwann, das sind hundert Jahre, wo Leute sagen, auch Leute sagen, auch Stefan Tietze, ja. Aber gibt es irgendjemanden, der darauf aufpasst, dass nicht, weil ist das denn, ist das denn schlecht für die Bevölkerung? Ja, Blüzei. Naja, aber es kann ja sein, dass, ich weiß nicht, ich hänge mich mit Biologie nicht so gut aus, es kann ja sein, dass der gesamte Genpool irgendwie schwächer wird, wenn jetzt plötzlich neun Generationen lang alle nur noch von Stefan Tietze befruchtet werden.
Und alle anderen Eigenschaften, die den männlichen DNA waren, einfach weggeschwemmt werden. Können wir nicht so die Welt retten? Also aus meinem Blickwinkel retten, aus anderen Blickwinkeln zerstören? Machen folgendes, wir tun in Merch-Shop sowohl deine DNA als auch meine. Und dann wäre ich sehr böse, wenn deine häufiger bestellt werden würde als meine. Misch die zusammen und schaut, wer sich durchsetzt. Guckt mal, guckt mal. Schaut einfach mal. Guckt mal. Aber da gibt es hundertprozentig Gesetze. Locker darf es nicht. Man darf nicht einfach sein. Da darfst du dir einfach Sperma in der Weltgeschichte rumschicken. Aber ich sag mal so, wir verkaufen ja T-Shirts.
Und wenn ihr ... Ich sag nichts.
Also nicht das wieder ... Aber falls es würde ...
Schaut mal im Merch-Shop vorbei.
Schaut mal vorbei.
Schaut demnächst mal wieder vorbei.
Ciao, macht's gut.
Das war das Podcast Ufo für diese Woche.
Das war das Podcast Ufo.
Wir freuen uns auf nächste Woche.
Macht's gut.
Wir heben ab, ciao!